we're awaiting new information tonight
about the potential fate of president
Trump's former national security adviser
special councils doing the paperwork
that will outline his recommendation for
the sentencing of Michael Flynn chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Harridge has the latest tonight on where
that investigation stands right now some
interesting late-breaking developments
as well good evening Catherine that's
right Bret and good evening confirmation
tonight the political operative Roger
stone is resisting a request for
documents and an interview with Senate
Democrats citing his Fifth Amendment
rights in a letter released by Senator
Dianne Feinstein stones lawyer describes
the request as quote to over-broad as
court filings this week suggests that
special counsel investigation is
entering a critical phase it is a climax
and a turning point analysts say the
legal filings on former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort the president's
former personal attorney Michael Cohen
and former national security adviser
Michael Flynn indicate Muller is
wrapping up loose ends in a cooperation
context when the government is ready to
make their filing and ready to go to
court for sentencing that generally
means that the cooperation by the
particular individual has come to the
end with a midnight Tuesday deadline the
Flint sentencing memo could come at any
time documenting his cooperation and
shed more light on he has contact with
Russian officials including ambassador
Sergey kis lyac after the presidential
election plan who pled guilty last year
to lying to the FBI over his
post-election contact faces a maximum
five-year sentence but what the plea
agreement significantly less time is
anticipated there are lingering
questions this past March the House
Republican Russia investigation found
that while Flynn pled guilty to lying
former FBI director James Comey and his
deputy Andrew McCabe testified their
agents saw no signs of deception with
McCabe telling the committee quote the
two people who interviewed Flynn didn't
think he was lying which was not a great
beginning to a false statement case on
Friday Comey is scheduled to appear
before House Republicans for a
closed-door interview under oath as
Muller team files new briefs on Manafort
who they accused of violating his plea
agreement as well as Cohen we're gonna
see the president respond very badly to
all of this as he
feels the walls are sort of closing in
on him the president said there's no
collusion Moeller has gotten no thing
nothing except commitments on perjury
and other things that are outside of
this
also today democratic attorneys general
for Maryland and DC issued subpoenas for
financial records for the Trump
Organization and Trump hotel here in
Washington arguing there may be
violations of the constitutional ban on
gifts from foreign governments Bret
Catherine thank you